Pour autant que nos connaissances nous permettent de l'affirmer,
la Terre, notre planète, est un cas unique dans l'univers.
Même dans ces contrées les plus arides, on découvre la vie.
Autour de l'équateur où la chaleur et l'humidité, ces éléments vitaux sont particulièrement denses, on trouve de grandes forêts.
Les plantes et les animaux y prolifèrent au point que
nous n'avons pu encore en identifier toutes les espèces.
Ici les animaux et les plantes, les insectes et les oiseaux, L'homme, enfin, cohabite dans des communautés intimes et complexes,
Dépendantes les unes des autres.
Les deux tiers de cette planète unique sont recouverts par l'eau,
Où la vie a pris naissance.
À partir des océans, la vie s'est répandue
jusqu'au sommet des plus hautes montagnes.
Plantes et animaux se sont adaptés aux différents milieux.
Ils ont évolué au gré des transformations de la terre elle-même.
*
La rivière Gandak que s'est frayée son chemin de manière étonnante,
Directement à travers la chaîne de
montagnes la plus haute du monde, l'Himalaya.
À l'Est, l'Annapurna, plus de 8000 mètres d'altitude,
à l'ouest, encore plus haut, le Dhaulagiri.
Leurs sommets ne sont distants que de 35 km et
je me trouve à leurs pieds 6000 mètres plus bas.
Cela signifie que cette vallée est la plus profonde du monde.
À l'altitude où nous nous trouvons environ 2000 mètres, il
fait suffisamment chaud pour que la vie animale et végétale,
Soit riche et abondante sur les 2 versants de la vallée.
Ces fleurs peuvent vous paraître familières, on en trouve en
effet dans bien des jardins, un peu partout dans le monde.
Mais ici, elles sont sauvages et elles poussent sur
leur lieu d'origine. Ce sont des rhododendrons,
L'une des 500 espèces de l'Himalaya. Des singes,
des langurs gris trouvent à s'y nourrir.
Et cela nous rappelle que les chaudes plaines
du sud Népal et les tropiques ne sont pas loin.
Ici vivent aussi plusieurs espèces de
faisans parmi les plus beaux oiseaux d'Asie.
Le fait que cette vallée soit la plus profonde du monde permet
d'y passer en quelques jours d'un site tropical a la base,
À des paysages polaires au sommet et d'observer, au fil de la promenade comment plantes et animaux s'adaptent parfaitement,
À ces conditions de vie changeantes.
En altitude, plus de rhododendrons mais dans la moiteur chaude
de l'été, on peut découvrir encore sur la mousse des troncs,
Des orchidées et sur le sol, des fleurs apparaissent en bouquet serré pour se protéger mutuellement des gelées nocturnes.
Le petit panda de l'Himalaya de la taille d'un renard est parfaitement protégé du froid par son épaisse fourrure,
Et par le fait que des poils lui poussent sous
la plante des pieds en gardant ceux ci au chaud,
Et l'empêchant aussi de glisser sur la glace.
Au sol, à peine plus grand que le panda, un des plus timides habitants de la forêt himalayenne, le chevreautin porte-musc.
Dans cet enchevêtrement d'arbres des bois
lui aurait été un handicap considérable.
Le chevreautin porte-musc ne les a donc pas développés. Pour attaquer, le mal dispose de défenses longues de 7 à 8 centimètres.
Dès qu'un animal meurt, quelle qu'en soit la taille,
arrivent les vautours. Ceux ci sont des vautours fauves,
Très semblables à ceux qui tournoient dans le ciel
des villages indiens, plus bas, au pied des collines.
On en trouve couramment jusqu'à 2500 mètres.
Ici, nous sommes à 3000 mètres, la forêt
s'éclaircie en été à cette altitude,
Les pluies sont rares et en hiver, il fait extrêmement froid.
Des conditions qui ne conviennent qu'au seul conifère.
Malgré l'altitude, le cours du Gandak est très large.
Bizarrement, la rivière ne serpente pas au pied des flancs de
ces montagnes géantes, mais coupe tout droit à travers elles.
Il y a longtemps que les populations qui vivent au pied
des collines exploitent cet extraordinaire couloir,
Qui les mène directement à travers l'Himalaya.
Durant tout l'été, des caravanes de mules remontent
la vallée, chargées d'orge et de sarrasin,
Qu'elles troquent avec les Tibétains en échange de laine et de sel.
Plus haut encore ne subsistent que de petits
arbustes et quelques touffes d'herbes desséchées,
Qui suffisent néanmoins à nourrir le tahr. Un curieux
ruminant qui tient à la fois de la chèvre et du mouton.
Autre créature typique de la montagne, le chocard à bec jaune.
Il s'élève jusqu'à la hauteur des pics
enneigés en utilisant les courants ascendants.
Seules fleurissent encore à cette altitude
quelques plantes rassemblées en coussin.
À proximité des sommets, ne subsistent enfin que les lichens,
Auxquels le froid n'autorise que quelques
jours de croissance par an.
Pourtant, des hommes vivent ici. Pour les aider
à labourer leurs champs, ils utilisent le yak,
Qui étaient autrefois en liberté dans les
plaines du Tibet et qu'ils ont domestiqués.
C'est le seul grand mammifère qui puisse
vivre en permanence à ces hauteurs.
Ces populations, les Bhotias et les Sherpas sont
parfaitement adaptés à la vie en haute altitude.
Leur sang est particulièrement riche en globules rouges, véhicule ainsi plus d'oxygène que celui des habitants de la plaine.
Ainsi donc, une fois de plus, l'environnement
a façonné, modifié, transformé les espèces vivantes.
Qu'elles soient humaines ou animales.
Mais toutes ces adaptations biologiques sont récentes.
Ces immenses montagnes, ces neiges éternelles,
Sont loin de remonter à la nuit des temps.
*
Elles sont plus jeunes, que les plaines de l'Inde
au sud ou que le plateau du Tibet au nord.
Elles se sont dressées à leur hauteur actuelle il y a
environ 65 millions d'années, jaillissant du fond de la mer.
*
Alors, qu'est-ce qui nous permet cette affirmation ?
On peut en trouver la preuve à cet endroit même.
Ces pentes sont recouvertes de curieux fragments, comme celui-ci.
*
Il s'agit à l'évidence d'un coquillage pétrifié, d'un fossile.
Bien qu'il n'existe plus aujourd'hui de mollusque comme celui-ci.
Il en existe d'autres, suffisamment similaires pour qu'on
puisse affirmer que cet ancêtre vivait lui aussi dans l'eau.
D'ailleurs, en analysant la roche dans laquelle il est pétrifié, nous voyons qu'elle était à l'origine de la boue marine.
Pourtant, je suis aussi loin de la mer qu'il
est possible de l'être au milieu de l'Asie,
À des milliers de kilomètres de la mer la plus proche, mais également à quelque 3200 mètres au dessus de son niveau.
Alors, quelles forces ont pu élever le lit de la mer à cette hauteur ? Nous savons maintenant que ces forces sont en action.
Nous savons que ces montagnes continuent de grandir et
que les continents sont toujours en phase de création.
Je suis ici en Islande. Cette fantastique fontaine de feu,
qui s'élève à 60 mètres, est composée de roches en fusion.
Tout autour tombe de la cendre fine. Il y a
des courants d'air suffocant, des gaz toxiques,
Et il fait tellement chaud que je ne peux m'en approcher davantage.
Des régions comme celles-ci ont de toute
éternité connu une intense activité volcanique.
*
À la chaussée des Géants en Irlande, il y a 50 millions d'années, après avoir forcé leur chemin à travers l'écorce terrestre,
Les laves se sont contractées en d'étranges
colonnes de basalte prismatiques.
Bien loin de là, aux Hébrides, on retrouve le même
type de colonnes, mais mesurant 6 mètres de haut,
Et recouvertes ici d'une couche de lave, non encore érodées.
Ces volcans d'Islande proviennent d'immenses fissures
qui s'ouvrent régulièrement sur toute la largeur de l'île.
Il s'agit en fait de l'extrémité septentrionale d'une
vaste chaîne de montagnes ou dorsales océaniques,
De plusieurs milliers de kilomètres. Creusées d'une
profonde fosse qui parcourt le globe du nord au sud.
*
La plus grande partie de cette faille
recouverte de stries de lave est sous marine.
C'est la raison pour laquelle son existence
n'a été découverte qu'au début de ce siècle.
Partant de l'Islande au bord du cercle arctique, elle traverse l'océan à distance égale de l'Europe et de l'Afrique à l'est,
Des Amériques à l'ouest. À certains endroits, elle surnage
pour créer des îles volcaniques les Açores, le Cap-Vert,
L'île de l'Ascension, Saint-Hélène, Tristan da Cunha.
Le basalte ne forme pas seulement les dorsales
océaniques, il déborde sur le fond de la mer.
Par analyse chimique, on a constaté que la lave la
plus éloignée du centre du sillon est la plus ancienne.
Le magma en fusion jaillit donc de la faille, se
solidifie ensuite en basalte de chaque côté de celle-ci,
Basalte qui est repoussé par de nouvelles remontées du magma,
si bien que le fond des océans est en continuelle expansion.
On ne connaît pas encore toutes les
forces qui engendrent ce processus,
Mais il semble qu'à une distance de 80 à 100 km
en dessous de la surface terrestre,
La chaleur est telle que la roche en fusion est parcourue
par des courants qui la font jaillir à travers la faille,
Et s'écoulait ensuite de chaque côté du sillon en entraînant
avec elle les grandes plaques de l'écorce terrestre.
C'est ce mouvement qui a entraîné la séparation de l'Afrique
et de l'Amérique du Sud et la création de l'océan Atlantique.
Des événements similaires se sont produits dans le Pacifique.
Le grand plateau qui forme la partie Est du fond de l'océan,
Est en mouvement en direction de la côte ouest de
l'Amérique. Mais à l'endroit où il rencontre le continent,
Poussé par un courant descendant, il
plonge sous la croûte terrestre,
Provoquant une profonde tranchée dans le fond de l'océan.
Il y entraîne les sédiments accumulés sur
le fond en même temps que de l'eau.
Mélangé au magma, ces nouveaux ingrédients constituent
une mixture nouvelle enrichie en gaz dissous et en vapeur.
En s'échappant vers la surface à travers les failles du sol, elle se refroidit, se solidifie et obstrue les cheminées d'accès.
L'effet est comparable au blocage de la
soupape d'une cocotte minute.
Le Mont Saint-Hélène, sur la côte Pacifique de
l'Amérique du Nord, le 18 mai 1980,
Une éruption au souffle 500 fois plus puissant que celui de la bombe d'Hiroshima éjecte plus d'un kilomètre cubes de roche,
À peu près un siècle plus tôt, en 1883, de l'autre côté du Pacifique, avait lieu une autre éruption spectaculaire,
Sur la petite île de Krakatoa, entre Java et Sumatra.
Cette éruption titanesque provoqua un raz de marée
développant des vagues de plus de 30 mètres de haut.
Les trois quarts de l'île disparurent tandis que deux petits
îlots proches étaient entièrement recouverts de cendres.
44 ans plus tard, un autre cratère jaillit de la mer.
Anak Krakatoa, l'enfant de Krakatoa.
Il connaît des éruptions sporadiques,
mais il est possible de parcourir ses bords.
Du volcan jaillissent en permanence des vapeurs et des gaz sulfureux qui, en se condensant, teignent la roche en jaune.
Les volcans ne demeurent pas éternellement actifs.
À terme, des modifications se produisent sous la croûte
terrestre et les foyers de chaleur intense se déplacent.
Si de l'eau filtre en surface, peut se créer une source thermale,
Un geyser telle que celle du parc
de Yellowstone en Amérique du Nord.
L'eau qui jaillit de ces fontaines naturelles est
d'une limpidité cristalline et chimiquement riche.
Mais tellement chaude qu'aucune créature ne peut y vivre. Par contre, dès qu'elle s'écoule en surface et commence à refroidir,
On y observe un foisonnement de colonies bactériennes
ainsi que la formation de tapis d'algues,
Sur lesquels apparaissent rapidement des insectes qui viennent
s'y alimenter et s'y accoupler, ce sont des ephydrides, ephydra,
Sortes de mouches d'une famille dont la caractéristique est
que la larve se développe dans des milieux aussi étrange,
Que le pétrole ou le formol.
Les œufs sont déposés à même le tapis
chaud constitué par les algues.
Chacun d'eux possède un long filament blanc comme une graine.
Ils sont loin d'être en sécurité, ils sont convoités par les mites qui escaladent les algues, par des araignées qui, elles aussi,
Rôdent autour de la colonie, par d'autres
mouches, enfin plus grandes que les ephydrides,
Et qui, elles aussi, se nourrissent volontiers de larves.
Ainsi, le tapis d'algues abrite et
entretient une communauté interdépendante,
Qui s'alimente des produits chimiques contenus dans l'eau
et qui puise son énergie dans la chaleur volcanique.
La colonisation d'une surface recouverte de
cendres volcaniques est particulièrement difficile.
Des années après son éruption, le mont Saint-Hélène
reste une terre désertique.
Sur Anak Krakatoa, dont l'existence remonte à une soixantaine d'années, le processus de colonisation est cependant en marche.
Non seulement il y existe des plantes géantes comme celle-ci,
une canne à sucre sauvage, mais également des arbres.
Voici un filao. Et si vous voulez voir le
résultat d'un siècle de colonisation par les plantes,
Regardez cette partie plus ancienne de Krakatoa.
*
Nous savons, grâce à des rapports
effectués il y a une centaine d'années,
Qu'à l'époque on ne trouvait ici qu'une couche de
cendre stérile de plusieurs mètres d'épaisseur.
En l'espace de trois ans, 34 espèces de plantes sont réapparues.
Dix ans plus tard, ce nombre avait doublé et était apparu,
entre temps, une centaine de races, d'oiseaux et d'insectes.
Certaines graines étaient parvenues en flottant
de l'île de Java, à 32 kilomètres d'ici.
Et le mouvement se poursuit. Certaines autres graines
ont sans doute été apportées par des oiseaux,
Soit sur leurs pattes, soit dans leur estomac. Il y a maintenant sur l'île plusieurs centaines d'espèces de plantes.
Les vents ont enfin amené d'innombrables insectes volants dont les descendants forment maintenant une vaste population permanente,
Qui assure la pollinisation des fleurs, s'alimentant de leurs fruits, de leurs feuilles, se nourrissant aussi les uns les autres.
Krakatoa et les nombreux autres volcan en éruption
qui s'échelonnent entre Java, Sumatra,
Et les autres îles de la région indonésienne se situent sur la ligne de faille de la croûte terrestre ou le plateau de basalte,
Formant le fond de l'océan Indien rencontre la partie
partiellement submergée du continent asiatique.
Cette jonction existait déjà il y a 65 millions d'années,
lorsque l'Inde était une île isolée au milieu de cet océan.
À ce moment, les continents se sont déplacés
et l'Inde s'est rapprochée de l'Asie.
Les sédiments qui les séparait se sont chevauchées par dessus la jonction, formant une immense chaîne de montagnes, l'himalaya.
Aussi, ces grands pics de grès et de calcaire culminant à quelque 8000 mètres ne sont pas seulement les plus hauts du monde,
Mais également parmi les plus récents.
Par ailleurs, le processus se poursuit. L'inde
continue son déplacement vers le nord,
À un rythme estimé à cinq centimètres par an. Elle se tasse ainsi toujours plus fortement contre la masse continentale de l'Asie,
Et même si c'est de manière infinitésimale,
l'Himalaya continue de grandir.
Voilà pourquoi cette ammonite, créature marine, se
retrouve ici à 3200 mètres d'altitude, dans l'Himalaya.
Voilà aussi pourquoi la rivière Gandak a
réussi à se tracer un chemin si parfait,
À travers la plus haute chaîne montagneuse du monde.
Elle coulait vers le sud venant de l'ancien plateau du Tibet, bien avant que l'énorme masse de l'Inde n'entre en contact avec l'Asie.
Pendant que les sédiments entre ces deux masses terrestres s'élevaient et s'entassaient pendant des millions d'années,
La rivière a maintenu son cours descendant à travers
la roche au fur et à mesure que celle-ci s'élevait.
Aujourd'hui, elle continue de couler vers le sud jusqu'aux plaines de l'Inde, à travers les gorges les plus profondes du monde.
Les animaux et les plantes ont réussi à s'adapter, à vivre même près des sommets, dans un environnement qui, avec celui des pôles,
Est certainement le plus inhospitalier qui soit.
De l'eau, des centaines de milliers de tonnes d'eau
reposent, gelées et sur les montagnes du monde.
On pourrait penser que cet endroit est l'un des moins propices
à la vie. Aucune végétation ne pousse sur ses champs de neige,
Et s'il n'y a pas de végétation et donc pas de
nourriture, il ne peut y avoir non plus d'animaux,
Tels que marmottes, souris ou lapins.
Et s'il n'y a pas d'herbivores, il ne peut y avoir de
carnivores, aucun prédateur, tels que faucons ou belettes.
En fait, il existe ici une quantité surprenante de vie, une forme de vie qui existe à l'intérieur du champ de neige lui même,
Parce que cette neige n'est pas blanche.
Elle est rouge.
Cette couleur provient d'algues microscopiques.
Elle est provoquée par la lumière qui se
réfléchit sur les parois de leurs cellules,
Ce qui est pratiquement invisible
lorsqu'on les examine au microscope.
Intérieurement elles sont vertes par la présence de chlorophylle, grâce à laquelle elles utilisent l'énergie solaire,
Pour transformer le dioxyde de carbone et l'eau en sucre.
Ces substances, ainsi que les minéraux dissous dans la glace fondante, apportent aux algues tous les éléments nécessaires,
À leur survie et à leur reproduction.
Les lourdes chutes de neige de l'hiver, les enfouiront
sous une couche de plusieurs mètres.
Mais au printemps, lorsque la surface de
cette couche fond, les algues se divisent.
Elles développent de petits cils grâce auxquels
elles rejoignent la surface et la lumière du soleil.
En vieillissant, alors que les minéraux
s'amenuisent, elles changent de couleur,
Formant d'énormes taches rouges sur les champs de neige.
Il n'est pas facile pour les plantes de
pousser sur les pentes escarpées,
Le passage continuel de la douceur relative du jour aux gelées
de la nuit fait que le terrain caillouteux et mouvant,
Est peu propice à la fixation des plantes.
En conséquence, les animaux herbivores sont rares.
Ces animaux dans les montagnes de l'Himalaya
sont des moutons bleus ou bharal.
Leur agilité les rend capables d'accéder
à la végétation de ces falaises.
S'ils sont peu nombreux, plus rares encore sont
les animaux qui pourraient en faire leur proie.
Durant l'été, le léopard des neiges a
été vu à 5400 mètres d'altitude,
Mais lorsque vient l'hiver, il est contraint de
se retirer dans les vallées,
Le gibier est maintenant si rare qu'il y en a tout juste assez, même sur un vaste territoire, pour nourrir un seul léopard.
Aussi cet animal est il un chasseur solitaire.
Les grandes montagnes d'Amérique du Sud, volcaniques pour certaines, tel le Cotopaxi, 5900 mètres d'altitude,
Font partie d'une chaîne qui parcourt toute la longueur
du continent, entouré par de vastes plaines froides,
L'altiplano, les versants de ces montagnes abritent une population vaste et variée d'animaux adaptés à la vie en haute altitude,
Et aux basses températures.
Ici vit la vigogne, c'est une sorte de chameau sauvage.
Son pelage fin et soyeux la protège efficacement du froid.
Or, c'est lui, paradoxalement, qui a conduit
la vigogne à une disparition presque totale,
Car l'homme la chassait intensément pour
l'intérêt que représentait cette laine superbe.
La population des Andes a domestiqué un autre chameau sauvage, Le Guanaco, qui non seulement lui procure aussi une excellente laine,
Mais lui sert également de bêtes de trait.
En Équateur et au Pérou, près de la ligne équatoriale,
ces animaux vivent jusqu'à plus de 4000 mètres d'altitude.
Plus au sud, en Patagonie et en Terre de Feu, le
guanaco vit par contre presque au niveau de la mer.
Il y développe un pelage tout aussi épais car l'hiver,
la terre ici est complètement couverte de neige,
Et les étés eux mêmes sont extrêmement froids.
Cette rigueur de la température, qui augmente à mesure
que l'on s'approche du pôle, est aisée à comprendre.
À l'équateur, les rayons du soleil
frappent le globe perpendiculairement.
Si l'on suit la courbe arrondie de la Terre, plus on se dirige vers les pôles, plus oblique est l'impact de ces rayons solaires,
Sur la surface de la planète. Aux pôles, leur effet
est donc réparti sur une surface plus grande,
Et ils doivent en outre traverser une
couche atmosphérique plus épaisse.
Au sud de la terre, baignée par les eaux glacées au large du cap Horn, une chaîne de petites île volcanique s'échelonne,
Jusqu'au continent antarctique.
Archipel du bout du monde, paysages grandioses et désolés
des îles Sandwich du Sud et des Orcades du Sud.
Seules deux variétés de plantes à fleurs peuvent survivre ici.
Et on n'y trouve aucune trace d'animal terrestre.
Par contre, les mousses et les lichens prolifèrent. Certains sont capables de survivre, gelés pendant plusieurs semaines,
S'alimentant sur eux, une ménagerie de minuscules animaux, créatures primitives à peine plus grandes que des têtes d'épingle,
Résistant au froid les plus intenses grâce au fait que leur sang contient une sorte d'antigel qui lui permet de rester liquide,
Même lorsque le thermomètre plonge bien en dessous de zéro.
Les mers entourant ces îles Antarctique sont
parsemés de blocs d'eau de mer gelée.
En hiver, ces blocs de glace vont jusqu'à
former une couche solide à la surface de l'eau.
Les icebergs sont d'une autre nature. Ce sont des
blocs d'eau douce, détachés du bord de la banquise.
Derrière la banquise, on découvre la
masse du continent antarctique.
Si le sol est stérile, les eaux environnantes
sont au contraire particulièrement fertiles,
Ainsi, la vie prolifère sur les bords du continent
et plus encore sur les plages des îles au large.
C'est le royaume des otaries à fourrure et des lions
de mer qui se nourrissent de bancs de crevettes.
Leur épaisse fourrure conserve l'air et leur
offre une isolation thermique lorsqu'ils nagent.
Les plus grands, les éléphants de mer
ont un système d'isolation différent,
Tout leur corps est entouré d'une épaisse
couche de graisse qui leur permet,
De se nourrir en eau plus froide et plus profonde.
Chaque année, à l'époque de la mue, ils perdent cette capacité,
Ils se rassemblent alors sur les plages et se blottissent
les uns contre les autres pour se tenir au chaud.
Si vous aviez à désigner un animal qui
symbolise les étendues glaciales de l'Antarctique,
Vous en choisiriez sans doute un du genre de celui-ci,
Un gorfou doré ou manchot macaroni.
Nous sommes sur l'île de Géorgie du Sud, à mi
chemin entre la Terre de Feu et l'Antarctique.
En fait, il semble qu'à l'origine, le manchot
évoluait dans des climats moins froids.
Aujourd'hui encore, certaines espèces vivent
proches de l'Équateur aux îles Galapagos.
Leur manteau isolant de plumes très dense, qui leur
permettait de nager au chaud sous toutes les latitudes,
Leur sert maintenant contre les vents froids de l'Antarctique, lorsqu'ils se tiennent debout sur terre ou sur un iceberg.
Ce sont de superbes nageurs. Non seulement ils sont rapides
et agiles dans l'eau, mais lorsqu'ils arrivent à terre,
Poussés par des vagues déferlantes qui écraserait n'importe quel bateau, ils semblent avoir l'élasticité d'une balle en caoutchouc.
Ces manchots à jugulaire mesurent environ 60 à 70 centimètres.
Le manchot royal, lui, mesure près d'un mètre, une grande
taille constitue un avantage sous les climats froids.
Plus grands est le corps plus petite est
la surface de peau par rapport au volume.
Un grand manchot retient donc mieux
la chaleur corporelle qu'un petit.
C'est en hiver que naissent les petits du manchot empereur, stoïquement planté sur la glace pendant deux mois,
Les mâles, seul, incubent les œufs jusqu'à
ce que les femelles reviennent de la mer,
Avec leur estomac rempli afin de nourrir les nouveau nés.
Ensuite, c'est chacun à leur tour que les parents iront
jusqu'à la mer pour apporter de la nourriture à leurs jeunes.
Mais maintenant que l'hiver touche à sa fin,
la mer est gelée sur une vaste étendue,
Et les manchots devront marcher parfois
80 kilomètres pour atteindre l'eau.
Les adultes ont un instinct parental très développé. Ceux qui
ont perdu un petit tenteront d'adopter un poussin errant,
D'autres iront même jusqu'à incuber un morceau de glace.
Tant que les poussins portent leur duvet,
ils dépendent entièrement des parents.
Sans leur plumage d'adulte, ils sont incapables
de nager et donc de se nourrir eux mêmes.
Inlassablement, les parents vont fouiller leur propre estomac pour y trouver de quoi rassasier leur petit perpétuellement affamé.
Semaine après semaine, ils effectueront leur
longue marche jusqu'à la mer en quête de nourriture.
Ce n'est que huit mois après leur naissance
que les jeunes auront enfin leur plumage définitif.
Alors, toute la communauté s'en ira vers la mer qui à nouveau,
avec le printemps et la débâcle des glaces, est toute proche.
Contrairement à l'Antarctique, qui est
un continent isolé par la mer,
L'Arctique englobe des régions terrestres d'Amérique, d'Asie et d'Europe, de sorte que des animaux d'Europe et d'Amérique du Nord,
Ont pu rejoindre cette partie gelée de la terre,
la coloniser et s'adapter à ses exigences particulières,
Ainsi, le renard de l'Arctique, dont le pelage
est plus léger que celui de son cousin du Sud,
Et qui devient complètement blanc en hiver.
La banquise est aussi le terrain de chasse de l'un
des plus grands carnivores au monde, l'ours polaire,
Qui a un lien de parenté évident avec
ses congénères d'Europe et d'Amérique.
Sa couleur blanche est évidemment une adaptation
à la couleur du paysage ambiant, et sa taille,
Beaucoup plus grande que celle de
ses cousins des régions tempérées,
Tient une fois encore au fait qu'un grand corps
retient plus aisément la chaleur qu'un petit.
Lorsque l'on s'éloigne du pôle, la Terre se
réchauffe suffisamment pour n'être plus recouverte,
Que partiellement par la neige et la glace.
C'est la toundra, un paysage de marécages,
d'étangs, de galets, de pierres et de graviers,
Où la vie pendant la courte période
de l'été présente une surprenante variété.
De petites fleurs poussent au ras du sol où le vent se
fait à peine sentir et ne perturbe pas l'effet du soleil.
Dans des terriers peu profonds habitent les moissonneurs de
cette maigre récolte de feuilles et d'herbe, les lemmings.
Durant l'été, quand sa nourriture abonde, cet
animal se reproduit à une vitesse stupéfiante,
La femelle peut mettre bas 5 à 6 petits par
portée, et cela 4 à 5 fois en une seule saison.
Cette prolifération attire bien entendu
des chasseurs comme le harfang des neiges,
Une sorte de chouette dont le lemming
constitue la nourriture principale.
À mesure que les jours rallongent, des hordes de
caribous arrivent en provenance du sud,
Accompagnés de leurs petits né plus tôt dans la saison.
Ils doivent se déplacer constamment afin de couvrir leurs besoins en nourriture et parcourent ainsi jusqu'à 25 kilomètres par jour.
Les oies des neiges sont également arrivées, certaines
de régions aussi lointaines que le Mexique,
Distant de près de 5000 kilomètres, pour se partager la riche moisson de secours été et pour donner naissance à leurs petits.
Il en existe deux variétés. La première a des plumes
sombres, la seconde, des plumes toute blanche.
Rapidement, la Toundra se couvre de leurs nids.
Les oies des neiges sont bientôt attaquées
par des nuées de moustiques,
Car de ces mares chaudes éclosent des myriades d'insectes
voraces, jusqu'à 100 000 au mètre carré en une saison.
À leur tour, ils constituent ici la nourriture
d'une phalarope à bec étroit.
Des larves de mouches noires qui ont passé tout l'hiver
agrippées au fond de la mare peu profonde commencent à émerger.
Le foisonnement de la vie est à présent intense,
car la lumière est pratiquement constante 24h sur 24.
Arrive la fin du mois d'août, l'oie des neiges, la première, ressent l'imminence de l'hiver et reprend le chemin du Sud.
Les caribous, à leur tour, reviennent sur leurs pas à
travers la toundra en continuant à se gaver de nourriture,
Afin de se constituer la réserve de graisse
qui leur permettra de passer l'hiver.
Au fur et à mesure que le temps se refroidit,
le besoin de trouver un abri se fait plus pressant,
Et les troupeaux parcourent maintenant
jusqu'à 40 kilomètres en une seule journée.
Finalement, les voyageurs sur le chemin du
retour atteindront les premiers grands arbres.
La vaste forêt de conifères qui s'étend au
sud de la toundra, tout autour du globe.
C'est le sanctuaire qui les protège de l'hiver glacial.
Le développement de la vie nécessite trois éléments.
De la lumière, de la chaleur et de l'humidité.
La raison pour laquelle des arbres tels que ceux ci ne
poussent pas plus au nord ne tient pas seulement au froid,
Mais aussi aux longs mois sombres de l'hiver.
Ils n'auraient pas assez de lumière
pour poursuivre leur croissance.
Ici, au nord de la Norvège, à 500 kilomètres du cercle arctique, cette lumière est à peine suffisante et le froid peut être extrême.
On a enregistré dans ces forêts des températures de -70 degrés.
Et en hiver, s'y produisent de très fortes chutes de neige.
Non seulement le froid menace de geler la sève des arbres, mais
il peut menacer leur approvisionnement en eau, gelée elle aussi.
De sorte qu'en hiver, cette région est en
quelque sorte aussi desséchée qu'un désert.
Les pins ont la même nécessité de stocker leur eau que les cactus.
C'est pourquoi leurs aiguilles sont protégées
par une peau épaisse, presque imperméable.
Cette peau n'est pas comestible. Par contre, les graines que contiennent les cônes des pins constituent durant l'hiver,
L'une des seules nourritures disponibles dans la forêt.
Grâce à un bec croisé qui lui a donné son nom, cet oiseau
a la possibilité de séparer les écailles des cônes,
Pour en sortir les graines.
Les campagnols se fraient un chemin à travers la neige
pour récolter inlassablement un maximum de provisions.
La forêt hivernale, ne pouvant ainsi nourrir que quelques herbivores, les prédateurs sont aussi peu nombreux.
La chouette lapone a des pattes particulièrement longues,
conçues pour agripper sa proie dans la neige.
Elle patrouille longuement car les occasions
de se nourrir sont plutôt rares.
Le lynx a de plus vaste appétit et il semble capable de
calculer le rendement de sa chasse de manière très précise.
Tout se passe comme s'il savait que s'il n'attrape pas
le lièvre qu'il convoite sur une distance de 150 mètres,
Eh bien la quantité de viande qu'il obtiendrait ne serait
pas suffisante pour compenser sa dépense d'énergie,
Alors, tout simplement, le lynx abandonne.
Les conifères de la forêt boréale poussent tout autour du globe, formant une ceinture de quelque 20 000 kilomètres de long,
Qu'on appelle la taïga.
À partir de la Scandinavie, elle s'étend à travers le nord de l'Europe, la Sibérie et jusqu'aux rives du Pacifique,
Et plus loin en Amérique du Nord.
Durant la dernière ère glaciaire, lorsque les mers étaient
plus basses, le détroit de Béring n'existait pas,
Et cette ceinture se prolongeait sans
interruption jusqu'en Amérique du Nord,
C'est la raison pour laquelle on retrouve
aujourd'hui pratiquement les mêmes espèces,
Dans les régions septentrionales d'Amérique, d'Asie et d'Europe.
Mais avec l'arrivée du printemps, les forêts de
chaque continent reprennent un caractère particulier.
En Scandinavie, la chouette épervière, une nomade qui
a passé l'hiver sous des latitudes plus hospitalières,
Réémigre au nord à la recherche de nourriture
et d'un endroit où bâtir son nid.
Le grand coq de bruyère ou grand tétras établit
son territoire de la Norvège à la Sibérie,
Ainsi qu'un des seuls mangeurs d'aiguilles de pin, le tétras lyre.
Des hiboux de différentes espèces viennent également
dans ces forêts nordiques pour y trouver leur nourriture.
Ils ne creusent pas leurs gîtes eux mêmes, ils comptent
pour cela sur les pics noirs, experts en la matière.
Leur bec acéré avec lequel il attrape les
insectes leur sert également de ciseaux.
Cela étant, ils préfèrent travailler les arbres
morts, dont le bois est passablement plus tendre.
L'anémone des bois est maintenant en fleur, de même que les pins.
Chaque arbre porte à la fois des fleurs mâles et femelles qui arrivent à maturité avec un certain décalage dans le temps,
Afin que les fleurs femelles puissent être
fertilisées par le pollen des autres arbres.
La chaleur est maintenant à son comble.
Les derniers visiteurs de l'été arrivent et toutes
les forêts du nord retentissent de leurs chants.
Ce pouillot fitis qui siffle si vigoureusement
en Scandinavie, a fait un long voyage.
Il vient du sud du Sahara, c'est également le cas de ce traquet.
Ils n'ont pas voyagé pour rien, ici, la nourriture abonde.
Il y a des myriades d'insectes.
*
Cette créature dépenaillé est difficilement reconnaissable
car ses ailes ne sont pas encore dépliées.
En fait, c'est un papillon, son premier souci est de
quitter le sol de la forêt qui grouille de dangers.
Il pompe ensuite un fluide à l'intérieur de son corps pour l'injecter dans les veines de ses ailes afin de les déployer.
Ici, les papillons déposent leurs œufs afin que les
chenilles puissent se nourrir sur les jeunes pousses.
Les fourmis des bois qui ont raté leurs proies au
sol vont en chercher d'autres sur les branches.
La couleur et la forme des chenilles leur permettent
de se dissimuler à la vue des oiseaux,
Par contre, elles n'ont aucune protection contre les
fourmis qui chassent à l'odorat et au toucher.
Les larves de la tenthrède forment un essaim sur les pousses de pin. Elles possèdent contre les fourmis une défense chimique,
En mangeant, elles emmagasinent une partie de la
résine des aiguilles de pin dans une poche buccale.
Quand une fourmi les attaque, elle lui dépose sur la tête une goutte de cette résine qui lui endommage les yeux et les antennes.
La fourmi est dès lors complètement désorientée.
Même si elle retrouve le chemin de son nid, elle continuera
à dégager une odeur telle que les autres fourmis,
La considéreront comme une intruse et la tueront.
Le torcol fourmilier est un membre de la famille des pics,
dont les fourmis constituent la proie privilégiée.
Comme ses cousins, le torcol fourmilier fait son nid dans
le tronc des arbres, mais il ne le creuse pas lui même,
Il préfère squattériser celui d'un autre pic.
Attirés en masse par la nourriture que
constituent les insectes et pour se reproduire,
Beaucoup de ces oiseaux quitteront bientôt ces
bois pour fuir les rigueurs de l'hiver qui s'annonce.
Certains, comme le grive mauvis, partiront
vers des pâturages plus au sud.
Le bruant, quant à lui, dès qu'il aura achevé sa mue,
s'envolera vers des régions plantées de hêtres.
Départs vers le sud aussi pour cette chouette épervière
menacée par le retour du froid et donc par la faim.
Sous sa route, la forêt change d'apparence.
Aux rangées de conifères sombres succèdent des arbres aux feuilles vert tendre, des chênes, des frênes, des hêtres, des bouleaux.
*
Ici plus au sud, la température est
plus douce, les étés plus longs.
Ces aires boisée sont épargnées par le gel, non pas deux ou trois,
Mais huit ou neuf mois dans l'année.
La forme des arbres est différente. Au lieu
de branches tombantes ployant sous la neige,
Celles-ci s'étendent largement avec d'innombrables rangées de feuilles qui permettent de capter l'énergie abondante du soleil.
Ces feuilles ne sont pas recouvertes d'une peau
protectrice, elles ont des structures fines et délicates,
Contrairement aux aiguilles de pin, elles servent
de nourriture appréciée à énormément de créatures,
À des animaux de grande taille comme les cerfs
qui en font une grande consommation,
Mais surtout en quantité bien plus grande encore,
elles servent de nourriture à tous les insectes.
La voûte de la forêt à cette période tardive de l'été,
abrite plus d'oiseaux qu'à aucun autre moment de l'année.
Les oiseaux migrateurs récemment arrivés en provenance
du nord et les oiseaux à demeure qui rassemblent,
De la nourriture en prévision de la seconde couvée de la saison.
On y observe également des oisillons qui
commencent à chercher eux-mêmes leur nourriture.
Hésitant encore à déterminer ce qui
est comestible et ce qui ne l'est pas.
La plupart d'entre eux vont à la chasse
aux insectes et la récolte est énorme.
Le Grimpereau est friand des insectes qui vivent sur les écorces, comme ce sphinx du peuplier qui essaie de se défendre,
En simulant la férocité.
La Sittelle fait habituellement son marché
en parcourant les troncs de haut en bas,
Afin de repérer des insectes qui auraient échappé à
l'appétit du grimpereau, explorant lui de bas en haut.
Les plus grands experts en la matière sont une fois encore
les pics dont le Pic épeiche est un digne représentant.
Son ouïe est exceptionnel. Il localise les
larves uniquement au bruit infime,
Qu'elles font en se déplaçant à l'intérieur des écorces.
Chaque continent possède sa propre gamme de pivert.
Il en existe dix espèces en Europe et
deux fois plus ici en Amérique du Nord.
Celui-ci le Sapsucker ou pic suceur de sève
perfore des trous dans les arbres,
Non pour chasser des insectes, mais pour recueillir de la sève.
Chaque trou est orienté vers le bas, de manière à ce que la sève ne puisse s'écouler à l'extérieur du tronc, mais à l'intérieur,
Où elle forme un petit réservoir auquel
se nourrit le suceur de sève.
Après l'été, le silence retombe sur les forêts et les feuillages délicats, incapables de survivre aux rigueurs de l'hiver,
Tombent au sol après être passés par tous
les tons de rouge et de brun.
Finalement, la terre est saisie par le gel. Beaucoup
de petits mammifères ont creusé leur trou pour hiberner.
Certains, comme l'écureuil terrestre ou Chipmunk, se réveille de temps en temps afin de rechercher de la nourriture,
Où de faire un peu d'exercice pour se réchauffer.
Dans les bois américains vit le plus spectaculaire de ces
dormeurs, l'ours noir, qui sommeille pendant des mois.
Cette femelle ne quittera pas sa tanière de tout l'hiver,
Pendant lequel elle continuera cependant
à réchauffer et allaiter ses petits.
Dans certaines régions du sud des États-Unis, les hivers sont suffisamment tempérés pour que certains arbres à feuillage larges,
Conservent celui-ci toute l'année.
Ici poussent également des pins qui,
paradoxalement, doivent leur existence au feu.
En cas d'incendie, les jeunes chênes brûlent en quelques minutes.
Les bourgeons terminaux des jeunes pins sont quant
à eux entourés d'une sorte de touffes d'aiguilles,
Qui brûlent à assez basse température.
Le temps qu'elle se consume, le foyer principal s'est déplacé,
Et au bout de la tige, le bourgeon à partir duquel
se développera un nouveau rameau est indemne.
Ces feux, généralement allumés par la foudre, sont de courte
durée, mais ils débarrassent la forêt de ses arbres morts.
Le Pic sait qu'il ne peut creuser son nid
en toute sécurité que dans des pins vivants,
Même si leurs bois sont si dur qu'il devra
creuser pendant deux ans pour construire son nid.
La sève résineuse suinte à l'endroit où
la brèche a été ouverte dans l'arbre.
Les oiseaux percent leurs trous très bas sur le tronc, là
où la sève ne coule pas et où le bois est assez épais,
Pour installer un nid suffisamment vaste.
L'écoulement de la résine est dévié vers l'extérieur par le
forage de canaux, au dessus et au dessous de l'entrée du nid.
Le nid est proche du sol. Son entrée est facilement repérable car elle est rapidement entourée d'une couche jaune de résine coagulé.
Le serpent ratier est un grand prédateur.
C'est un grimpeur extrêmement adroit.
Le fait que l'ouverture du nid du pivert soit assez basse
et donc relativement facile à atteindre par le serpent,
Semble exposer les habitants du nid à un danger considérable.
Mais la véritable fonction de la
résine va maintenant vous apparaître.
*
Les composants chimiques de cette résine irritent
la peau du serpent et l'obligent à s'arc bouter,
Pour s'éloigner du tronc jusqu'à la chute.
Les dégâts provoqués par les feux peuvent souvent être
constatés dans les forêts de pins du sud et de Californie.
Cet arbre mesure douze mètres de large à la base et 80 mètres de hauteur. C'est un séquoia géant que l'on estime âgé de 2500 ans.
Cet autre séquoia, baptisé General Sherman, est légèrement
plus grand. Son poids est estimé à près de 1400 tonnes.
C'est l'organisme vivant le plus lourd au monde.
On pense qu'il a entre 3500 et 4000 ans.
Et les séquoias se sont développés en Amérique
du Nord durant l'ère glaciaire.
Mais il y a 8000 ans, quand la Terre a
commencé à se réchauffer, ils ont disparu,
À l'exception de quelques groupes isolés dans les montagnes de la Sierra Nevada enneigée pendant pratiquement six mois de l'année.
Les conifères doivent une grande partie de leur prolifération à leur capacité d'adaptation aux climats changeants du Nord.
Ils peuvent survivre aussi bien aux jours sombres et glacés
de l'hiver qu'à la chaleur et aux feux ravageurs de l'été.
Si nous descendons plus bas vers le sud, à 1600
kilomètres d'ici, nous arrivons sous les tropiques,
Où le climat est radicalement différent.
Plus de variations véritable, mais un niveau constant
de lumière, de pluie et de chaleur durant toute l'année.
*
C'est la force de gravitation qui maintient autour de
la Terre les nuages et l'air dans lequel ils flottent.
L'air impalpable et invisible, à ce point
omniprésent qu'on finit par en oublier l'existence.
L'air sans lequel pourtant les graines
et les insectes, les oiseaux et les hommes,
Seraient incapables de s'arracher à l'attraction terrestre.
Les graines de pissenlit flottent parce que
le moindre souffle de vent peut les soulever,
Et elles retombent très lentement car leur
corolle retient l'air comme un parachute.
C'est ainsi qu'elle traverse les plus vastes océans
pour atterrir sur les îles les plus lointaines.
Les graines de pollen sont si petites que la présence de
duvet n'est pas nécessaire pour les maintenir dans l'air.
Les inégalités microscopiques de leur surface sont suffisantes.
Les spores expulsées par la vesse de loup sont encore plus petits.
Le moindre souffle les éparpille aux alentours
par dizaines de millions comme de la fumée.
La filandre ou fil de la Vierge, qui parfois recouvre
les prés, est l'équivalent animal des graines duveteuse.
Elle est produite par des milliers de petites araignées.
Dès leur naissance, ces araignées grimpent au sommet
des tiges d'herbe ou sur de petits tas de gravier.
Elles dirigent leur abdomen vers le haut et à partir de leur
glande filières, elles produisent un fil de soie très fin.
À mesure que celui-ci s'allonge, le vent l'emporte.
À un moment donné, la petite araignée se retourne. Elle saisit le fil avec ses pattes antérieures et se laisse emporter par lui.
Seuls les plus petits et les plus légers des animaux et des
plantes peuvent défier les lois de la gravité de cette façon.
Beaucoup de graines sont trop lourdes pour être ainsi
transportées par le vent, même si elles sont très duveteuses.
Par contre, celles qui sont produites au sommet d'un arbre
élevé peuvent au contraire exploiter la gravitation.
Ces graines ci, qui poussent dans la jungle du Venezuela,
possèdent des ailettes conçues de telle façon que,
Lorsqu'elles tombent de l'arbre, elles tournoient.
Leur descente est ralentie et le vent peut les entraîner,
À une certaine distance de l'arbre dont elles proviennent.
Certains animaux, comme ce gecko volant du Sud-Est
asiatique, peuvent parvenir à un résultat comparable,
Grâce à des orteils palmés qui leur permettent
d'amortir la vitesse de leur chute.
Dans la même forêt, un autre lézard réussi à planer lui aussi,
en étirant de véritables ailes de peau à partir de ses flancs.
Mais le champion de cet exercice est cet écureuil volant dont l'énorme manteau de peau pendante constitue un véritable parachute.
En vol horizontal, il peut même faire mieux.
Tout comme cela se produit sur l'aile d'un avion lorsque
l'air attaque le bord frontal de son manteau tendu,
La pression se réduit sur la surface supérieure de
celui-ci et l'écureuil peut alors légèrement s'élever.
Toutes ces créatures planantes peuvent contrôler leur direction, mais elles sont généralement incapables de se propulser très haut.
Paradoxalement, c'est plus près du sol,
dans la végétation des hautes herbes,
Que l'on trouve des créatures qui ont
de véritables aptitudes au vol.
Le mouvement le plus exigeant est le décollage.
L'insecte doit se hisser dans l'air
à la seule force de ses muscles.
Par un balayage circulaire de ses ailes, il augmente rapidement
la pression sous lui et se trouve ainsi aspiré vers le haut.
Des insectes plus grands comme les sauterelles, accentuent
cet effet par un bond puissant au moment de quitter le sol.
L'envol des oiseaux, beaucoup plus lourds,
réclame plus d'énergie encore.
Les oiseaux utilisent également leurs pattes musclées pour soulager le travail de leurs ailes. Ils sautent, ils s'élancent dans l'air.
Les oiseaux les plus grands pour décoller doivent augmenter
la vitesse du courant d'air par dessus leurs ailes.
Ils ne peuvent s'envoler sans avoir pris de la
vitesse en s'appuyant sur le sol ou sur l'eau,
Exactement comme le fait un avion au décollage.
Une fois dans l'air, les animaux volants de toutes sortes pénètrent un environnement complètement différent et ils l'exploitent à fond.
Les demoiselles trouvent leur nourriture dans l'aire.
Elles s'y accouplent et même elles s'y battent.
Ce sphinx dépose ses œufs sur les fleurs tout en
volant car il est trop lourd pour s'y poser.
Il s'alimente également en vol stationnaire en face de la
fleur dont il suce le nectar avec une trompe filiforme.
Ce colibri, le calypte d'Hélène, est
encore plus petit que le Sphinx,
Il a cette même aptitude à battre des ailes jusqu'à 80 fois
par seconde pour se maintenir en l'air quasi immobile,
Pendant qu'il boit dans le calice des fleurs.
*
Les ailes des oiseaux sont mieux adaptées que celles des
insectes, car leurs plumes s'ajustent de manière idéale,
Glissant aisément les unes sur les autres, permettant
de varier la forme et la surface de ses ailes.
Elles peuvent de la sorte s'étendre largement lorsqu'elles s'abaissent, puis, pendant le mouvement ascendant,
Se rétrécir pour offrir moins de résistance à l'air.
La réduction de la pression de l'air sur la surface des ailes, qui facilite l'élévation, peut être parfaitement observée au ralenti,
Car elle a pour effet d'aspirer les petites plumes vers le haut.
L'albatros est expert dans l'art de s'élever
en s'appuyant sur les courants ascendants.
Là encore, la réduction de la pression produite lorsque
l'air passe sur les ailes déployées de l'oiseau,
Entraîne un hérissement des plumes.
Lorsqu'il doit voyager contre le vent, l'albatros descend près de la surface de l'eau, car les vagues diminuent la force de la brise.
Les falaises sont des lieux de prédilection pour les planeurs comme l'Albatros. Elles dévient vers le haut le vent venant du large,
Et permettent ainsi aux oiseaux de décoller aisément ou
de rester comme suspendus en l'air pendant des heures,
Dans ses courants ascendants.
La chaleur peut permettre aussi de s'élever dans l'air.
Dans une montgolfière, cette chaleur est produite par
des becs de gaz et l'air ascendant est si puissant,
Qu'il permet d'entraîner vers le ciel une
lourde nacelle et plusieurs passagers.
Nous sommes en Afrique et nous nous dirigeons vers
les grandes plaines à gibier du Serengeti.
Alors que le soleil réchauffe la terre, d'autres courants d'air chaud se forment naturellement au dessus des blocs de rochers,
Ou de pentes nues qui, plutôt que d'absorber
les rayons du soleil, les réfléchissent.
Cette ascendance thermique est
particulièrement appréciée des vautours.
Ces grands oiseaux possèdent des ailes à leur mesure.
Pénible à mettre en mouvement.
Le matin, les oiseaux se contentent de voleter d'un arbre
bas à l'autre, ils attendent que la terre se réchauffe.
À présent, un vautour va venir nous rejoindre.
Un rocher qu'il affleure est en train de s'échauffer au soleil.
L'air au dessus de lui va s'élever et c'est exactement ce
dont a besoin le vautour pour s'envoler facilement.
Les vautours grimpent toujours davantage, utilisant les
courants thermiques pour scruter sans effort la plaine,
Où défilent la plus grande concentration de bétail du monde.
Avant la nuit, un gnou au moins aura été la victime des prédateurs.
Les vautours ont maintenant pris leur essor.
À plusieurs centaines de mètres d'altitude ils peuvent
rapidement déceler la présence d'un animal mort.
Si c'est le cas, ils plongent vers le sol, dès qu'un oiseau
a repéré une carcasse, des douzaines d'autres arrivent.
Ceux-ci sont des vautours de taille moyenne, des
vautours de Rüppell ou des vautours à dos blanc.
Mais parmi eux se trouve l'un des plus grands
des vautours africains, le vautour nubien.
Dans ces montagnes africaines comme dans certaines autres d'Asie
et d'Europe, vit une espèce de vautour, le gypaète barbu,
Qui a un mode d'alimentation très particulier.
Il se nourrit non seulement de moelle, mais des os eux-mêmes.
Et pour cela, il utilise une technique singulière. Il
porte tout d'abord ses os jusqu'à un véritable atelier.
C'est un rocher dénudé.
L'oiseau le choisit proche du bord de la falaise.
Ainsi, le vautour pourra s'envoler plus aisément
s'il doit transporter un os très lourd.
Il ne lui reste maintenant qu'à prendre de l'altitude
et à lâcher son fardeau sur le rocher enclume,
Où il va se briser en menus morceaux.
Certains grands corbeaux procèdent de la même manière,
mais généralement avec beaucoup moins de discernement,
Quant au choix du terrain.
Maintenant, il ne reste plus au gypaète qu'à consommer son repas.
Les chouettes ont également des ailes très
développées. Mais pour une autre raison.
Leur grande portance permet à la chouette de
ne pas devoir les battre bruyamment.
Et c'est vital pour un animal qui, s'il veut atteindre ses proies nocturnes, doit les approcher dans le plus grand silence.
Ses plumes sont même bordées d'un duvet très doux
qui leur sert en quelque sorte de silencieux.
Bien que les chouettes chassent après la tombée de la nuit,
elles s'orientent grâce à la grande acuité de leur vue.
Et leur vol silencieux leur permet de déceler le moindre
crissement révélant la présence de campagnols ou de souris.
Quand les nuits sont complètement noires, même une
chouette ne peut cependant s'y orienter,
ces nuits là appartiennent aux seules chauves souris.
Elles sont capables de se diriger dans l'obscurité
totale. Elle dispose d'une sorte de sonar naturel.
Elle pousse des cris dans la gamme des ultrasons et
se guide sur les échos qui leur proviennent en retour.
Elles sont adroites, au point de gober une mouche en plein vol.
Les oiseaux ont une telle maîtrise de l'air et une telle
capacité à rester en vol pendant des journées entières,
Qu'ils sont devenus les plus grands voyageurs du monde animal.
Au dessus de Panama, en octobre et en novembre,
on peut en observer des nuées impressionnantes.
Les faucons et les vautours, aura ou cathares, fuyant l'arrivée de l'hiver, s'envolent pour un séjour de quelques mois plus au sud.
À mesure que le temps se réchauffe, ils trouvent les courants thermiques qui leur permettent d'atteindre l'altitude,
Nécessaire pour effectuer leur vol moyennant un minimum d'effort.
Les oiseaux ne sont pas les seuls à accomplir ces immenses
parcours intercontinentaux. Aussi incroyable que cela paraisse,
Des créatures en apparence très frêles peuvent en faire
autant. Des insectes s'envolent ainsi avec une volonté tenace,
Sur la trace des oiseaux migrateurs les plus endurants.
Ces papillons monarques sont nés en
automne dans les bois d'Amérique du Nord.
Ils viennent d'arriver à Mexico après un voyage extraordinaire de plus de 3000 kilomètres. Ils se reposeront ici quelques mois,
Ensuite, ils effectueront le voyage du retour,
se nourrissant et s'accouplant en vol.
Finalement, quelques uns rejoindront les bois de leur naissance.
Ainsi, la Terre est survolée d'itinéraires d'animaux migrateurs.
Aux Amériques, la plupart transitent par Panama, bien que
quelques audacieux choisissent l'étape des Caraïbes.
Ces trajets peuvent atteindre des milliers de kilomètres.
L'enveloppe atmosphérique, elle, n'a
que huit kilomètres d'épaisseur.
C'est une altitude que l'on peut atteindre en montgolfière, mieux équipée toutefois que celle utilisée précédemment en Afrique,
Car à cette hauteur, un système
d'approvisionnement en oxygène est nécessaire.
Maintenant, nous sommes très près des limites
de cette atmosphère qui enveloppe la planète.
C'est à cette altitude que se produisent que
se déterminent les variations météorologiques.
Le temps qu'il fait à la surface de la
Terre se joue ici dans la haute atmosphère.
Les molécules d'eau s'évaporant de la surface des
mers et des lacs par la chaleur du soleil,
Ainsi que celles produites par les plantes sous
forme de vapeur, s'élèvent de la surface de la terre,
Et en même temps se refroidissent, se condense
pour former des nuages de gouttelettes.
Déplacés au gré des vents, ces nuages s'évaporent et se re-condensent, se forment et se reforment.
Les plus grandes perturbations de l'atmosphère
sont dues à de gigantesques courants thermiques,
Provoquées par le Soleil dans un ciel chargé d'humidité.
Les molécules d'eau à l'intérieur des nuages se condense
pour former des gouttelettes de plus en plus grandes.
L'air s'élève rapidement et les maintient
suspendues à l'intérieur des nuages.
Finalement, leur poids les entraîne
sous forme de pluie torrentielle.
Un orage tel que celui-ci peut apporter la mort et la destruction.
Il peut aussi apporter la vie car les pluies qu'il engendre sont distillées par le soleil à partir de la surface des océans.
Ces pluies y sont donc constituées d'eau fraîche non salée, indispensable à toute forme d'existence sur la Terre.
Ces sources d'eau douce ne constituent
que le prélude d'un long voyage.
Situées dans les hauteurs des Andes, elles aboutiront, avec d'autres innombrables, au fleuve le plus long de la terre,
L'Amazone.
Gonflées de poussière, de roches et de boue, elles
sont déjà riches de substances nutritives.
Elles dévalent les pentes à une vitesse impressionnante.
Et toutes les créatures qui y vivent se
doivent de nager à la perfection.
Ce qui est le cas des Merganettes armées ou canard des torrents.
Ces oiseaux exploitent les remous et
les tourbillons avec une habileté consommée,
Pagayant puissamment grâce à leurs pattes palmées. Ils remontent
le courant. Ils s'ancrent au rocher avec leur queue,
Et, pour assurer leur prise, utilisent de petits
éperons cornés situés à l'articulation de leurs ailes.
Mais qu'y a-t-il à manger dans ces eaux froides et tumultueuses ?
On y trouve de la mousse, comme dans tous les cours d'eau du monde.
Une mousse qui procure un abri à
une multitude de larves, d'insectes.
En été, ces créatures viendront brièvement
voler au dessus de la rivière pour s'accoupler.
Mais l'essentiel de leur vie se passera sous l'eau. Certains sont littéralement profilées pour résister au courant.
Les larves des phyganes s'abritent dans des tubes protecteurs,
le creux d'un roseau ou une construction de débris de bois.
En bâtissant leur abri à base de lourds grains de sable. Certaines se lestent elles mêmes afin que le courant ne les emporte pas.
La larve de la simulie se maintient à
un caillou par une sorte de crochet.
Même si elle perd prise, tout n'est pas perdu.
Un fil de soie, une sorte de ligne de
survie, la relie à son attache.
En remontant ce fil, elle regagne son
port pour s'y assurer une nouvelle prise.
Par sa glande filières, elle déroule un tampon de
soie très fin auquel elle s'amarre à nouveau.
La simule a développé des antennes modifiées, sorte
de filet avec lesquels elles capturent sa nourriture.
Les petits cours d'eau qui dévalent les pentes de la vallée pour alimenter les fleuves naissants ont leur propre population.
En Malaisie, les tortues à grosses têtes
ou platysternon sont aquatiques.
Elles remontent les chutes d'eau en se servant
de leur queue très longue comme point d'appui.
Dans ces autres chutes en Afrique occidentale et nulle part ailleurs, vit l'extraordinaire grenouille poilue.
Les poils en question sont en fait des
filaments implantés sur ses flancs,
Et qui lui servent de branchies pour absorber l'oxygène de l'eau.
Autres appendices inhabituels, ses griffes
qui l'aident à s'agripper aux cailloux.
Dévalant d'une hauteur de quinze cents mètres,
les innombrables sources qui alimentent l'Amazone,
Rejoignent les eaux brunes d'un véritable
affluent, épaissi par la boue et les sédiments.
Le débit du torrent charriant sable et graviers
sculptent à présent les flancs de la montagne.
Quand le courant se heurte à une roche plus dure,
telle une ancienne coulée de basalte,
Sa progression est temporairement contrariée.
Il passe par dessus la barrière en un pic.
Ainsi se forment les plus belles cascades, comme ces chutes d'Iguazu aux frontières du Brésil, du Paraguay et de l'Argentine.
À la base, le flot frappe les roches jusqu'à ce qu'elles se fendent, ainsi, les chutes tracent leur chemin vers l'aval,
En laissant en amont des gorges profondes.
Des animaux vivent ici, à l'intérieur même des chutes, comme ces martinets qui nichent sur la façade rocheuse derrière la cascade.
Chaque jour, ils se rassemblent très
haut au dessus du fleuve Iguazu.
Après une partie de chasse aux insectes, ils rallient
leur nid en jaillissant à travers l'écran aquatique,
Qui les protégera pour la nuit.
Et le fleuve s'éloigne, laissant derrière lui
ses sources montagneuses. Son aspect a changé.
Ces eaux se sont enrichies en éléments nutritifs.
Au fil de l'Amazone, la jungle s'épaissit. Des oiseaux comme
le caurale soleil se promènent en quête de nourriture.
D'énormes poissons croisent dans les
eaux qui s'écoulent plus lentement.
L’Arapaima, un des plus grands poissons d'eau
douce. Ils mesurent près de deux mètres.
L'amazone contient près de 3000 espèces de poissons différents.
Les poissons chats demeurent au fond du fleuve.
Leurs antennes sensitives leur permettent de se frayer
un chemin à travers les fonds les plus boueux.
Certains d'entre eux sont capables de se défendre en déchargeant
de l'électricité, d'autres possèdent des ventouses ventrales,
Ou dorsales qui leur permettent de s'agripper aux rochers.
Rien qu'en Amérique du Sud, on recense 1200
espèces différentes de ces poissons chats.
Dans ces eaux surpeuplées, beaucoup de poissons offrent
à leur progéniture une protection particulière.
Celui-ci, le discus, va plus loin.
Il procure à ses petits un menu particulier, une sécrétion visqueuse spéciale qu'il produit sur ses flancs,
Et dont ils se nourrissent.
Plus le fleuve évolue, plus il ralentit son
cours. Le moindre obstacle suffit à le freiner.
À l'extérieur de chaque courbe, le flux érode la rive à
l'intérieur de la courbe, là où le courant est plus lent,
L'eau dépose sa charge de sédiments.
Ainsi, avec le temps qui passe, les courbes du
fleuve se rapprochent les unes des autres.
Au fil des ans, elles prennent le chemin le plus court.
Les terres qui les séparent finissent par s'effondrer,
Le fleuve raccourcit son tracé.
À la longue, certains méandres deviennent des
lacs rapidement envahis par la végétation.
Ces feuilles sont celles du célèbre Victoria
regia, le nénuphar géant de l'Amazone.
Une plante aquatique agressive qui se développe au
détriment de celles, plus modestes qui l'entourent.
Au départ, ces feuilles ont la taille d'une assiette à soupe.
En quelques jours, elles atteignent deux mètres de diamètre,
Soit une croissance de quelque trois centimètres carrés par minute.
Leurs nervures remplies d'air leur font supporter le
poids de lourds oiseaux aquatiques, tel le jacana.
Auxquelles des pâtes aux doigts largement étalés permettent d'ailleurs de se déplacer sur des feuilles bien moins résistantes.
Il se nourrit d'insectes et il n'a ici que l'embarras du choix.
Cet hydromètre est installée sur une feuille, mais il pourrait l'être aussi confortablement sur la surface de l'eau,
Car celle-ci constitue une plateforme tout à fait
susceptible de supporter de petites créatures.
Les molécules d'eau sont reliées entre elles par une force de cohésion qui crée en surface une tension relativement ferme.
L'hydromètre transperce sa victime et se nourrit de sa substance.
Le film de tension qui se forme à la surface de
l'eau ne sert pas seulement de plateforme aux insectes,
Il constitue également une caisse de résonance qui
leur permet de détecter l'approche d'une proie,
De faire des signes d'alerte ou de lancer des messages de séduction.
Le notonecte comme l'hydromètre patrouille à la surface,
à la recherche d'une proie, mais sous marine celle-là.
Ainsi, ces deux insectes se partagent l'essentiel de ce
qui peut-être pris au piège sur cette pellicule aquatique.
Ce coléoptère, qui vit sur les plantes
des berges, a quelques talents divers.
Il évolue à la surface de l'eau avec une particulière agilité.
Il est capable aussi de produire une substance
qui le propulse à une vitesse accélérée.
Enfin, entre autres performances et comme la plupart
des coléoptères, il est même capable de voler.
L'amazone charrie une masse de sédiments couleur ocre depuis
ses sources des Andes jusqu'à sa jonction avec le Rio Negro,
Qui, lui, ne charrie que des eaux sans limon, seulement teintées
de noir ou de vert par des substances organiques dissoutes,
Car il descend du Nord-Ouest où les terres sont
constituées de roches dures et nues.
Pendant plusieurs kilomètres, les deux fleuves ne
mélange pas leurs eaux qui foisonne de nourriture,
Et la vie sur les berges est florissante. Des hordes de
rongeurs géants, les Capybaras ou Cabiaï, y prospèrent.
Ces animaux amphibie sont d'excellents
nageurs. Leurs pieds sont palmés,
Leurs yeux, leurs oreilles et leurs narines sont
tous situés sur le sommet de leur tête,
Ce qui leur permet, lorsqu'ils pénètrent dans l'eau, de continuer à voir, à entendre et à sentir ce qui les environne en surface.
Les loutres géantes ont des caractéristiques physiques similaires.
Cette espèce amazonienne bat tous les records de taille.
Certains spécimens atteignent près de deux mètres de long.
Il s'agit d'une vaste famille représentée dans
beaucoup de fleuves aux quatre coins du monde.
Une multitude d'oiseaux, revendique également
sa part de pêche dans le fleuve.
Voici un harle couronné. C'est une espèce apparentée aux
canards dont le bec long, étroit et bordé d'entailles,
Et fait sur mesure pour attraper les
poissons aux écailles glissantes.
Dans la phase ultime de leur cheminement, ces grands
fleuves, souvent, ne maîtrisent plus leur cours.
Leurs lointains affluents, des montagnes gorgées d'orages, déverse d'énormes quantités d'eau qui les font largement déborder.
Chaque année, l'Amazone connaît des crues qui inondent
des dizaines de milliers de kilomètres carrés de forêt,
Et qui lui font atteindre en certains
endroits douze mètres de profondeur.
Les premiers à profiter de ces inondations sont évidemment les poissons qui y puisent des trésors de nourriture supplémentaire.
Arrivant au bout de leur course à la mer, les fleuves finissent
de déposer les sables et les boues qu'ils ont charriés,
Sur des centaines, des milliers de kilomètres.
Là, les plantes aquatiques et les poissons prolifèrent, attirant des nuées d'oiseaux comme ces oies des neiges au nord du Canada,
Ou ces autres oies à l'autre bout du monde, dans
un delta tropical de Papouasie-Nouvelle-Guinée.
Le delta de l'Amazone est immense,
étalé sur plus de 300 kilomètres.
À travers ce labyrinthe, ce sont trois quarts des eaux
fluviales du globe qui vont finalement rejoindre l'océan.
C'est un monde aquatique intermédiaire, ni vraiment doux,
ni vraiment salé, où les flots vont et viennent,
Où la terre et l'eau sont en continuel déplacement.
Un monde aux frontières duquel la Lune,
décrivant son orbite autour de la Terre,
Provoque deux fois par jour les grandes marées océaniques.
En même temps qu'elle érode les côtes, la mer
dépose sur les plages des masses de débris,
Qui provoquent au contraire une avancée de la terre.
Sous les tropiques, les palétuviers croissent aux pieds de
l'océan, rassemblent de la boue autour de leurs racines,
Et créent ainsi des territoires nouveaux, les mangroves.
Où que ce soit comme ici dans l'estuaire d'un fleuve
anglais, lorsque l'eau douce rencontre l'eau de mer,
Elle dépose des sédiments remplis de nourriture
qui attirent aussitôt de nouveaux habitants.
Ce petit crustacé, le corophium, mesure un cm environ.
Il se nourrit de bactéries qui prolifèrent par millions,
Brisant les substances organiques qui pourrissent dans la boue.
Les Nérisses, sont des vers qui vivent
dans des trous. Ils s'attaquent au corophium,
Se nourrissent d'algues, de bactéries, pratiquement
de tout ce qui se déplace autour d'eux.
Sur les mares flottent un mucus produit par des coquillages en forme de tête de flèche, pas plus grandes que des grains de blé.
Le mucus attire les bactéries et les coquillages mangent le tout.
À l'abri dans son tube La Sabelle, une espèce de vers elle aussi, déploie ses tentacules pour attraper des particules organiques,
En chute lente vers le fond.
Les filaments de l'éventail sont en continuel mouvement afin
de faire descendre les particules vers l'orifice buccal,
Situé au centre de cette sorte de tube. En même temps
qu'elle se nourrit, elle éjecte un ciment de boue,
Et de mucus qui consolide le rebord du tube.
La coque repose sur le fond avec sa coquille béante.
Elle filtre l'eau en l'aspirant à travers un
siphon et en la chassant à travers un autre.
Les moules utilisent la même technique pour récolter
à l'intérieur de leur coquille des particules nutritives.
La marée, en se retirant, expose certains coquillages. Des milliers se trouvent parfois rassemblés sur une surface d'un mètre carré.
Tous ces mangeurs de boue constituent une
prise très riche et les amateurs ne manquent pas.
Les bécasseaux en migration sont régalent et c'est à longueur d'année que les échassiers viennent s'alimenter aux estuaires.
La barge bénéficie de grandes pattes et
d'un long bec qui lui permettent d'évoluer,
Et de se nourrir dans des eaux profondes de plusieurs centimètres.
Le courlis préfère travailler au sec. Son bec effilé lui permet
de sonder la boue en profondeur pour y attraper des vers.
Le bécasseau variable, le plus petit, recherche
des prises à sa mesure, des larves d'insectes.
Le gravelot n'a qu'un très petit bec et ne peut
saisir que de la nourriture flottant en surface.
En général, il travaille en solitaire de manière que sa proie
ne soit pas alertée par d'autres piétinements de pattes.
Quant à l'avocette, c'est par un mouvement de fauchage de son bec recourbé qu'elle attrape les créatures vivant dans la boue liquide.
À mesure que les fleuves y apportent de nouveaux sédiments,
les marécages augmentent en largeur et en profondeur,
Développant à leur surface une croûte limoneuse d'algues microscopiques qui entament le processus de consolidation.
Rapidement, des plantes plus grandes y
implantent leurs racines, telle la salicorne.
*
Ensuite, le processus s'accélère. La marée montante
apporte de nouvelles particules de boue,
Qui s'accumulent autour des tiges de salicorne
et qui ne repartiront pas avec le reflux.
Ainsi, à chaque marée, les marécages
prospèrent de plus en plus profonds.
La salicorne pousse dans les estuaires
froids de l'Europe sous les tropiques.
Les colonisateurs de bout ne sont pas de petites plantes
mais de véritables arbres, les palétuviers,
Dont il existe aujourd'hui une quarantaine d'espèces différentes.
Les fleurs de ces palétuviers sont pollinisées par le vent.
La graine ne quitte pas immédiatement son
arbre d'origine, elle y entame son développement,
En produisant une pousse verte d'une trentaine
de centimètres avec une extrémité effilée.
Si elle tombe à marée haute, elle flotte horizontalement
et peut parcourir des kilomètres avant de s'échouer.
Si elle tombe à marée basse, elle se plante dans la
boue et le retour des eaux ne landais logera pas.
Rapidement, elle développe des ridicules vers le bas, des
feuilles vers le haut et en l'espace de quelques jours,
Elle est fermement installée.
Même si cela ne paraît pas évident, le Périophthalmes
est un poisson. Il en existe plusieurs espèces,
Celui-ci vit près des lignes de marée haute et
il passe l'essentiel de son temps hors de l'eau.
Il doit conserver sa peau humide car
c'est à travers elle qu'il absorbe l'oxygène.
Il conserve également la bouche pleine d'eau
pour en alimenter de temps à autre ses branchies.
Il se nourrit de petits crabes qu'il trouve dans la boue.
Une autre espèce vit près des lignes de marée basse et
ne passe hors de l'eau qu'une heure ou deux par jour.
Elle tamise la boue liquide à la recherche
de ver et de petits crustacés.
Une troisième espèce, enfin la plus courante et qui est végétarienne, s'alimente d'algues et autres plantes microscopiques.
Ceux ci protègent leur territoire avec
vigueur en l'entourant de fortifications.
Et cela jusqu'à former un patchwork de réservoirs cloisonnés. Ces appartements plats et peu profonds impose aux Périophthalmes,
De curieuses gymnastiques à l'heure de la quête amoureuse.
Enfin, le mal a réussi à convaincre une
femelle de le rejoindre dans son bassin privé.
Il peut continuer à lui faire sa
cour de manière plus conventionnelle.
Autour des racines de palétuviers, les crabes appelants
ou crabes violonistes sont en pleine activité.
Les femelles ramassent de la boue avec leurs
deux pinces et la mâche à une cadence d'enfer.
Les mâles en consomme la même quantité, mais ils
ne disposent pour la récolter que d'une seule pince.
L'autre est à ce point développé qu'elle leur
est inutile dans leurs exercices de mastication.
En fait, elle ne leur sert qu'à faire signe aux femelles
de passage pour les encourager à les suivre dans leurs trous.
Lorsque vous aurez un petit moment, arrêtez
vous de mâcher de la boue et passez dont me voir.
À marée basse, la nourriture ne manque pas autour des palétuviers.
Les sternes chassent le poisson, plus facile à
attraper maintenant que les eaux sont moins profondes.
Les martins pêcheurs font quant à eux une
grande consommation de crabes appelants.
Avec la marée montante arrivent de nouveaux bancs de poissons.
Des poissons avides de ce que le fleuve
aurait pu déposer à marée basse.
Dans les marécages du Sud-Est asiatique, le
toxote ou poisson archer, se nourrit d'insectes.
Il a une façon bien à lui de les attraper.
Par un rapide coup de langue, il leur expédie un jet
de gouttelettes, comme le ferait un pistolet à eau.
Étourdi, l'insecte tombe à la surface de
l'eau ou l'autochtone s'empresse de le gober.
Aux endroits où la terre s'enfonce dans les eaux en un pic.
La zone qui sépare les marais est évidemment beaucoup plus réduite.
Les créatures qui y vivent sont
constamment en proie à deux dangers.
À la ligne de marée haute, il y a le risque
de s'échouer sur le sol et de s'y dessécher.
Et à la ligne de marée basse, il y a le risque de se
faire attraper par des animaux venant des profondeurs.
Chaque espèce vivant sur ce terrain étroit développe des
forces qui lui permettent de compenser ses points faibles.
Certains, ne pouvant supporter qu'un bref séjour à l'air libre vivent au niveau le plus bas possible, comme l'oursin,
Qui se nourrit d'algues.
Hors de l'eau, il n'a d'autre solution
que de s'accrocher provisoirement au rocher.
C'est ce que font également ces anémones de mer géantes
qui replient leurs tentacules car à l'air libre,
Elles ne captent rien à manger et les ascidies ne
peuvent filtrer l'eau et s'alimenter qu'épisodiquement.
Les étoiles de mer sont carnivores.
Celles-ci se nourrissent de moules.
Elles les recouvrent de leurs bras pourvus de petites ventouses
et forcent lentement leurs coquilles pour les dévorer.
En dessous de la ligne de marée basse. Aucune moule n'y résiste. Mais comme beaucoup de créatures de cette zone,
Une fois sortie de l'eau, les étoiles
de mer sont impuissantes à s'alimenter.
Les moules choisissent donc pour s'installer des rochers
exposés alternativement aux flots et à l'air libre.
Les moules ne peuvent résister à des vagues très violentes.
Aux endroits les plus exposés. Elles sont remplacées par les balanes, petits crustacés fixés qui ont une plus grande résistance.
Ainsi, chaque part de la rive est envahie par
des organismes les mieux adaptés à ces combinaisons,
Très précises de conditions physiques et biologiques.
Le mouvement incessant de la mer finit par réduire les rochers de la côte en sable que le flot déposera au bord des baies abritées.
Ici vivent d'autres communautés intermédiaires.
Un petit nombre seulement s'aventurent
au dessus de la ligne de marée haute.
C'est le cas de tortues qui y sont
contraintes, en quelque sorte par atavisme.
Celle ci est une Lepidochelys du Pacifique.
Avec ses 60, 70 centimètres de long,
Elle est sans doute la plus petite des tortues de mer.
Comme toutes ses congénères, elle descend de reptiles terrestres et ses œufs ne peuvent toujours se développer qu'à l'air libre.
Après s'être accouplée en mer, elle
débarque donc sur la côte pour y pondre.
Au Costa Rica, ce débarquement ressemble à une
véritable invasion au rythme de 5000 tortues à l'heure,
Et seulement sur deux ou trois plages qu'elles se
sont choisies parmi les centaines que compte la région.
Plus surprenant encore, elles n'envahissent ainsi les
plages que pendant certaines nuits, en aout et novembre.
Si leurs nageoires sont efficaces en mer, au
sol elles ne leur sont que d'un piètre usage.
Elles sont à peine capables de les traîner sur le sable.
Cette ponte massive et sporadique est une protection pour
les œufs, qui sont ainsi moins menacés par les prédateurs.
Chaque femelle pond une centaine d'œufs
pour des raisons mal connues,
Rarement plus d'un de ces 100 oeufs produira un
petit qui regagnera ensuite la mer.
Sur d'autres plages, plus discrètement, d'autres
tortues très différentes ont entamé leur ponte.
Celles-ci sont les plus grandes de toutes les
tortues marines. Ce sont les splendides tortue luth.
La tortue luth est un animal très mystérieux.
C'est un vagabond solitaire des océans.
On en trouve pratiquement dans toutes les zones tropicales et d'autres ont été signalées très loin de là, en Argentine,
Dans les îles Britanniques ou encore en Amérique du Nord.
On sait très peu de chose d'elle, sinon qu'elle
se nourrit d'oursins de mer et de poissons.
Mais elle est aussi très friande de méduses. On
ignore la durée moyenne de vie des tortues luth.
On ne sait rien de leurs habitudes d'accouplement.
On ne sait pas non plus comment les femelles s'orientent,
Pour trouver leur site traditionnel de ponte.
En fait, jusqu'il y a 30 ans, on en avait jamais découvert. La reproduction de ces mastodontes restait un mystère complet.
Depuis lors, on a repéré quelques unes des plages où
elles pondent sur la côte du Suriname, en Amérique du Sud,
Et ici sur la côte Est de la Malaisie.
*
Les populations locales, elles, étaient bien entendu au courant
de leur présence et elles pillaient d'ailleurs leurs oeufs.
C'est une pratique qui n'a pas disparu, malheureusement, au contraire. Aujourd'hui, on pille les œufs de tortues de plus belle.
On met ainsi en danger la survie même de
cette créature énorme et extraordinaire.
Mais peut être la tortue luth a-t-elle
heureusement des lieux de ponte inconnus,
Sur l'une ou l'autre île de corail perdue
dans l'océan, hors de la portée des hommes.
Si vous voulez découvrir une île du bout du monde,
pourquoi pas celle-ci ? Aldabra, dans l'océan Indien,
La terre la plus proche est l'Afrique, à 400
kilomètres à l'ouest. C'est en fait un groupe d'îles,
Qui font partie de l'ancien continent
de Gondwana, aujourd'hui immergé.
Celle-ci est anatol au sommet d'un volcan
éteint jailli de la mer il y a 50000 ans.
Elle est devenue maintenant le logis de milliers d'oiseaux de mer, tels ses frégates qui ont volé pendant d'innombrables kilomètres,
Pour venir se poser sur les palétuviers
qui poussent en bordure de la côte.
La plupart des plantes environnantes ont dû venir
à la surface de l'eau sous forme de graines.
Une noix de coco peut flotter pendant
plus de quatre mois avant de mourir.
Celle-ci est bien vivante et rien ne l'empêcherait
de croître en bordure de la plage.
En grandissant, les cocotiers inclinent la tête par dessus
la mer. Ainsi, les noix tombent à l'eau et à marée haute,
Elles s'en vont coloniser d'autres îles.
L'habitant le plus célèbre d'Aldabra, le voici, c'est une
tortue géante. La plupart des tortues flotte naturellement.
Si l'une d'entre elles, se nourrissant sur un palétuviers
de la côte africaine, venait à être emportée par la mer,
Elle pourrait survivre suffisamment longtemps pour être amenée par les courants jusqu'à ces îles de l'océan Indien et s'y développer.
C'est d'ailleurs certainement de cette manière que les
ancêtres des tortues géantes d'Aldabra sont arrivés ici.
La vie sur cette île est éprouvante. Le soleil tropical
frappe les animaux, menace de les cuire littéralement,
À l'intérieur de leur carapace et les traces
d'accidents de ce genre sont courantes.
Lorsque la chaleur augmente, les tortues partent à la recherche
de l'un ou l'autre abri susceptible de leur procurer de l'ombre.
Ici et là, sur certaines plages balayées par
le vent, poussent quelques bosquets qui, à midi,
Sont encombrés de groupes de tortues venues se réfugier
là en attendant que reviennent un peu de fraîcheur,
Qui leur permettra de repartir à la recherche
des feuilles comestibles constituant leur repas.
Cela fait donc 50 millénaires qu'Aldabra a émergé.
En termes d'évolution, ce n'est pas une durée considérable.
Elle est suffisante cependant pour apporter des modifications,
Aux caractéristiques physiques des animaux
qui vivent ici, dans l'isolement.
Ils se sont transformés par rapport à leurs ancêtres
qui ont colonisé l'île, mais ils sont aussi différents,
De leurs actuels proches cousins partout dans le monde.
Plusieurs espèces d'oiseaux ont ainsi subi des changements, parfois légers, mais qui les rendent désormais uniques en leur genre.
Partout ailleurs, l'Ibis sacré a les yeux
sombres, ici, ils sont bleu clair.
La crécerelle d'Aldabra est plus petite que celle
de Madagascar et le Souimanga ou nectarin de l'île,
A un plumage plus foncé que ses parents d'Afrique.
Les reptiles insulaires semblent avoir une
tendance au gigantisme, comme la tortue d'Aldabra.
Un autre grand format célèbre vit sur l'île de Komodo,
en Indonésie. C'est le plus grand lézard du monde.
Connu sous le nom de varan géant ou dragon de Komodo.
Il n'est pas difficile d'en rencontrer. Il suffit d'une
carcasse de chèvre, de préférence en état de décomposition.
Son odeur va les attirer à des kilomètres à la ronde.
On pensait autrefois que ces animaux étaient exclusivement nécrophages, qu'ils se nourrissaient uniquement de charognes.
Nous savons maintenant qu'ils peuvent se muer en tueurs actifs.
Ils attaquent et ils tuent les chèvres,
les bufflons et même à l'occasion, l'homme.
Si je peux les approcher sans trop de risque, c'est qu'ils
ont une très mauvaise vue et sont pratiquement sourds.
Ils y suppléent par de bonnes qualités olfactives et gustatives.
Ainsi, avec un peu de chance, l'odeur de ces chèvres mortes sera plus forte que la mienne et ils ne s'intéresseront pas à moi.
Ce sont en fait les rois de cette île
dont ils sont les plus grands prédateurs.
Il n'y a aucun animal ici à qui ils pourraient servir de proies
et aucun non plus qui puisse leur disputer leur nourriture.
C'est sans doute ce qui, dans leur isolement,
a permis qu'ils aient atteint une telle taille.
Ils peuvent mesurer jusqu'à trois mètres et peser
une cinquantaine de kilos, et même davantage.
*
Komodo n'est pas, comme Aldabra, un atoll qui s'est
développé à partir du sommet inondé d'un volcan,
Mais les restes érodés d'un volcan bien plus grand qui s'est
élevé à des centaines de mètres au dessus du niveau de la mer.
Les volcans sont en effet à l'origine de la plupart des îles isolées et les îles Hawaï elles-mêmes sont toutes volcaniques,
La plus grande et la plus récente d'entre
elles étant d'ailleurs encore en éruption.
Sur ces hautes îles s'accumulent les nuages chargés d'humidité.
Sur leurs côtés, exposés au vent, les chutes de pluie tombent dru.
Des cours d'eau dévalent les flancs des montagnes, traversant des couches peu compactes de cendres, érodant des vallées profondes.
Ainsi, contrairement aux atolls qui constituent
une plateforme de corail et de sable et de roches,
S'élevant à quelques centimètres seulement au dessus du
niveau de la mer, ces immenses île volcanique d'Hawaï,
Offrent une grande variété d'habitats à leurs colonisateurs.
Des hautes pentes froides recouvertes de cendre aux
basses vallées bien irriguées, chaudes et humides.
Là, du basalte récent et lisse, plus loin, d'antiques
forêts poussant sur d'anciennes coulées de lave.
Pour exploiter tout cela, les éléments colonisateurs
ont adopté une multitude de formes.
Le Palila fait partie d'une grande famille
d'oiseaux hawaïens nectarivor, les drepanidés.
Leurs ancêtres étaient sans doute des pinsons transportés
ici il y a des milliers d'années par de fortes tempêtes.
Sur place, ils ont développé plus de 30 espèces, chacune
avec son alimentation et son habitat particulier.
Le palila se nourrit de graines. Il possède,
pour les briser, un bec court et puissant.
La Maki est un de ses parents. Son corps est similaire mais
son bec est plus mince, adapté à attraper de petits insectes,
Et à sucer le nectar des fleurs.
Certaines espèces ont des plumages chatoyants
qui distinguent le mâle de la femelle.
Elle ne se croise pas avec les espèces cousines,
si bien qu'elles deviennent de plus en plus spécifiques.
Ainsi la Papane à tête rouge, très voyante, à un grand bec
approprié à son régime, presque exclusivement composé de nectar.
*, qui possède une petite crête de plumes blanches à la base du bec, a une alimentation mixte composée de nectar et d'insectes.
Lishui vermillon a le bec long et recourbé, ce qui lui permet
de sonder profondément les fleurs en forme de trompette.
Le plus attachant, enfin, est sans doute **** avec son bec splendide à double fonction, la mandibule inférieure pique,
Et écarte l'écorce pour y déloger les insectes,
La mandibule supérieure allongée sert à les extraire.
Il utilise l'une et l'autre avec une rare dextérité.
Des êtres humains ont débarqué à Hawaï il y a environ quinze cents ans et c'étaient des Polynésiens, de remarquables marins.
Ils naviguaient sur l'océan à bord de canoës à flotteurs
pouvant transporter plusieurs centaines de passagers,
Et dont la taille était double de celle des canots
encore utilisés de nos jours dans le Pacifique.
De leur base située à Samoa, atteinte par leurs
ancêtres plus de 1000 ans avant notre ère,
Ils ont colonisé les îles les unes après les autres,
vers Hawaï au nord et vers l'île de Pâques à l'est.
Mais leur plus grand périple, ils l'ont effectué au sud, parcourant 6500 kilomètres d'océan pour atteindre la Nouvelle-Zélande.
À leur arrivée il y a 1500 ans, la terre qu'ils découvrirent
là était très différente de celle d'où ils venaient,
Avec des chaînes de montagne et des forêts inextricables contenant beaucoup plus d'animaux et de plantes que les atolls de corail.
Car cette terre fit autrefois partie d'un plus vaste continent peuplé des ancêtres de ses habitants actuels. En voici un.
Le tuatara ou sphénodon, un reptile nocturne au troisième oeil fonctionnel qui se nourrit de vers de terre et d'insectes.
Il ressemble à un lézard, mais il est
plutôt apparenté aux dinosaures.
Partout ailleurs, son espèce s'est éteinte depuis longtemps.
Autre relique de ce continent disparu le kiwi.
Le kiwi n'a pas d'ailes visibles ni de queue, et il vit
dans un trou au fond duquel il pond un oeuf énorme.
Le plus grand, proportionnellement à la taille chez les oiseaux.
Ses longues plumes flottantes ne lui permettent pas de voler.
Avec son air hirsute, lorsqu'il court sans bruit
sur le sol à la recherche de sa nourriture,
Il fait plutôt penser à un mammifère.
Et effectivement, il a un peu fait fonction de mammifère
dans ces îles où à l'origine il n'en existait pas.
Si son bec l'apparente aux oiseaux, le
kiwi s'en sert de manière étrange.
Il le plonge profondément dans la terre pour sentir les vers
dont il se nourrit, comme le ferait un mammifère.
Depuis que la Nouvelle-Zélande est devenue, il y a
quelques millions d'années, ce groupe d'îles isolées,
Des oiseaux plus récents y sont apparus, comme cette
espèce de pigeon, le Kereru, ou ce perroquet, le kéa.
Ses ancêtres à lui sont venus d'Australie. Il s'est adapté à
la vie froide des hautes montagnes où il se nourrit de baies,
De racines et d'insectes, mais aussi de charognes comme un corbeau.
Le fait de vivre sur cette île a fait subir à
cet autre perroquet, le kakapo, une profonde mutation.
Il n'y a pas sur cette terre de mammifères qui mangent de
feuilles. Cet oiseau en a fait son alimentation essentielle.
Cet animal nocturne extrêmement nerveux vit
en effet de la végétation qui l'entoure.
Il est particulièrement caractéristique
des animaux qui peuplent l'île.
Sa seule défense est de se mettre en arrêt comme il le
fait là. Il ne bouge plus et il attend que passe le danger.
Le kakapo est aussi un géant. C'est le plus grand de
tous les perroquets. Il peut peser plus de trois kilos.
Et ce poids, cette grande taille sont à
l'origine d'une troisième caractéristique.
De tous les animaux de l'île, celui-ci est un des plus vulnérables.
*
Les ennuis du kakapo ont commencé quand
sont arrivés les Polynésiens qui l'ont chassé.
Ils avaient apporté avec eux une sorte de rat qui dévasta les nids.
Lorsque, des siècles plus tard, débarquèrent des Européens, ils introduisirent sur l'île d'autres tueurs, l'hermine et le chat.
De nos jours, ne demeurent que quelques douzaines de kakapo.
D'innombrables prédateurs ont été importés ici des
putois et des opossums d'Australie comme animaux familiers.
Des lapins d'Europe pour leur chair et leur fourrure,
et même des cerfs pour les plaisirs de la chasse.
Tous ont eu un effet dévastateur sur l'environnement, allant
même parfois en débarrassant la terre de ces plantes,
Jusqu'à provoquer une sévère érosion du sol.
Tant que l'homme continuera, comme en Nouvelle-Zélande,
à ne pas se conduire en protecteur actif de la nature,
Ces étranges animaux seront condamnés, comme
l'ont été leurs ancêtres aujourd'hui disparus,
Comme l'a été le Dodo de l'île Maurice,
exterminé par d'autres hommes.
Les créatures que vous trouvez sur ces îles
ne passent pas nécessairement tout leur temps ici.
Certaines, comme ces voyageurs infatigables que
sont les fous n'y viennent que pour se reposer.
De même que les frégates et beaucoup d'autres oiseaux de mer, ils trouvent leur nourriture non sur les îles où ils nichent,
Mais dans la mer où prolifère une autre
communauté complexe de plantes et d'animaux.